this year
each of the nominees for leading actor
uh has brought to the big screen some of
the most inspired and
harrowing work that we've ever seen in
this category
in a normal year
any one of these performances would have
stood out as the most challenging
imaginative and ambitious of the year
and so tonight the academy has had
to
the difficult task of
honoring
the finest among equals
the nominees
for leading actor
in a motion picture are
bradley cooper silver linings playback
daniel day-lewis lincoln
jackman
joaquin phoenix the master
denzel washington flight
and the oscar goes to daniel day-lewis
daniel day-lewis is the first actor to
win three oscars in the lead actor
category
oh
i really don't know how any of this
happened i
um
i do know that i've received so much
more than my fair share of good fortune
in my life and i i'm so grateful to the
academy for this beautiful honor
it's a strange thing because
three years ago
before we decided to do a straight swap
i had actually been committed to play
margaret thatcher um
and uh meryl was
was was stephen's first choice for
for lincoln um and
i'd like to see that version
um
and um
stephen didn't have to persuade me to
play lincoln but i had to persuade him
that perhaps if i was going to do it
that lincoln shouldn't be a musical
um
my fellow nominees my equals
my betters
i'm so proud to have been included as
one amongst you um
when we got married 16 years ago uh or
since we got married 16 years ago my
wife rebecca has lived with some very
strange men
um
i mean they were strange as individuals
and probably even stranger if taken as a
group
but luckily she's the versatile one in
the family and she's been the perfect
companion to all of them
i'd like to thank uh kathy kennedy our
producer and through you kathy
and
and through you our our mighty team of
co-conspirators
at the apex of that human pyramid
there are three men to whom i owe this
and a great deal more
tony kushner
our beloved skipper steven spielberg
and the mysteriously beautiful mind body
and spirit
of abraham lincoln
for my mother thank you so much